so what we have here is the world's
first webcam this is a little single CCD
camera it took black-and-white images
not in very high resolution as I recall
it was probably might have been 500
pixels across that sort of number maybe
700 it might have been a powell signal
but but we didn't often actually use it
at that resolution because storing that
kind of quality of image and
transmitting it was a bit hard on the on
the networks most of the networks of the
time so this was 1991 the web was just
starting about then first few web
browsers were around but not very many
people knew about them at this point and
I was working in the university computer
lab where in the university computer lab
here now or the department of computer
science and technology as it's now
officially called but in those days it
was in a much nastier building over in
the center of town and I was part of a
group that was working on multimedia
over computer networks back in those
days we didn't know how good this could
be networking standards were still being
developed we didn't know whether
Ethernet or ATM or token ring or someone
was going to be the one that won we were
looking at things like how good a frame
around higher higher quality how much
color can you get could you do broadcast
quality video over computer networks we
didn't know that at the time so a lot of
people in the group we're working on how
you create this sort of stuff how you
transmit it how you store it how you
process it in real time and so and that
meant that we had various fun bits of
multimedia kit lying around in a way
that really wasn't very common at the
time and but we that there was also
something that was very important for
computer science research has always
been important for computer science
research and that's a good flow of
coffee this dates I think partly back to
the time when you had to book you know
time on the mainframe late at night and
so you know you needed the coffee to
keep you awake while you were working
but we computer scientists get through a
lot of coffee and we had this
particularly bad coffee
in the lab in those days and it was
shared between about 15 of us working in
this group and most of us worked in the
same room so the coffeepot was right
there it was a sort of filter drip
machine thing and it never made very
good coffee
but it particularly didn't make good
coffee if it was stale if it had been
sitting there for some time and you
didn't get it when it first came through
the filter it was really bad so some of
us worked in that room but some people
in the group worked in rooms down the
corridor or even two or three floors up
and they would often come down and they
wouldn't have we felt they didn't have
Fetty and a fair share of access to the
fresh coffee and and because we had some
bits of kit lying around like you know
little cameras that we could actually
connect to computers cameras that you
could connect to computers were pretty
rare in those days this was actually the
first one we used we grip this in a kind
of retort stand and pointed it at the
coffeepot and my friend Paul jet-ski
wrote a little bit of software on one of
our dedicated machines in the rack that
would capture images from this once
every we captured them about once every
10 seconds or something maybe maybe
faster than that I don't know but and I
wrote a little app this was at the time
an X Windows app that would display a
little icon sized image of the coffee
pot you run my app and it would appear
in the corner of your screen that meant
that people who particularly people who
weren't nearby could just glance down
see what the state of the coffeepot was
and know whether it was worth a trip
down stairs around the corner or
whatever to get to get a fresh cup and
it was built on some experimental RPC
protocols we were using at the time you
had to be running our special networking
stack and but it all worked very well
and we threw it together very quickly
not because we were particularly
brilliant but because a lot of guys in
the group had been doing their PhDs or
other research on this for some years
and so we had a lot of the tools there
to take images from cameras and and put
them in get them into computers and
interestingly of course it was video
that we were getting out of the cameras
in those days
digital still cameras actually decent
ones didn't come along for quite a while
after that but we did have video cameras
which would output a video signal and
then you would have a frame grabber card
which would capture individual frames
and turn into memory and turn those back
into video in the computer and they were
about three frames a minute or something
that we actually displayed in in in the
little window of the app which was fine
because the coffee pot filled up very
slowly and emptied fairly slowly so that
would give you sufficient data for your
coffee making decisions and they were
also grayscale images but we hope that
didn't matter because the coffee was
pretty grey as well and so this was
sufficient so it was a sort of
disruptive view of the video everyone
else in the group including me had been
working on what's the best quality the
best resolution the best color you can
get and we discovered that it was
actually also really useful to point a
camera at an inanimate object and get I
think it was about a hundred and twenty
pixels square maybe even less than that
in grayscale low framerate video that
actually could still serve a useful
purpose in 1993 web browsers started to
get the ability to display images before
that you could display text you could
change the size a little bit you could
change the color I think you could
change the background of the page but
you couldn't really do you know very
much more than that and then the image
tag in HTML which let you embed images
started to come into the mosaic browser
in in early 93 spring of 93 I think and
we thought oh this is interesting
what would happen if the browser went to
the web server and said please give me
this this image and the server didn't
give back the same image every time we
didn't know would the browser have
cached it would it get confused would it
only ask once because up to that point
most people had just been using images
to show graphs of their results or
pictures of their girlfriends or the
logos of their institution usually and
it was all very static so we thought hmm
where have we got a source of constantly
changing images aha the coffeepot camera
so my friends Dan Gordon and Martin
Johnson took this stuff that was coming
out of here and was using our own RPC
protocols and network stacks and so on
and just quickly bolted on a thing that
let it be access there's a probably a
gif actually over HTTP this new HTTP
protocol it works very nicely and we
could create a little web page and it
meant that people in the group did not
have to be running our specific
networking stack and my particular
little butt and so on they could just go
to one of these newfangled web pages and
see how much coffee was in the coffee
pot which was good but as a side effect
it meant that everybody in the world
could also see how much coffee was in
our coffee pot and we didn't realize
this but it turned into quite you know
initially we never knew this would be
this would happen but it turned into
quite a novelty quite a popular novelty
we call it a meme now I guess on the on
the early web because back in those days
there weren't really weren't very many
things to look at on the early web and I
think we're still talking about a time
when browsers didn't even have bookmarks
you know favorites menus because there
were so few sites out there that you
could you know you could remember the
ones who the URLs of the things he
wanted to look at so you were browsing
around and all of a sudden you came
across this page where a group had done
this crazy thing of taking what was then
a very valuable bit of technology and
pointing it at this rather grotty
looking coffee pot simply so they could
get fresh coffee and that kind of caught
people's imagination and it became
something of an icon in the the early
days of the web eventually we did decide
however that it had run its course and
it was time to turn it off and so we
turned the camera around and pointed it
at the computer that had been taking all
of these images over the years and the
very last image this captured was that
all of our fingers pressing the off
switch of the computer that had been
running it for those 10 years that
computer that was turned off
ceremoniously was it was it the same one
all the time and was its own capture
card or had you had to
make changes and we I think it was
changed once the very the very first
software ran on we we had these racks of
single board computers plugged into a VM
e bus for people who remember those kind
of things they were they were designed
specially for this project mostly one or
two of them were standard but they as I
recall it was a board about this size
that had a frame grabber card alongside
it and and this was connected into the
the frame grabber card and and the
software ran on there under our own
operating system and after a while that
Hardware proved somewhat unreliable and
we ended up switching to an Archimedes
so I think for most of its life it was
was an Archimedes computer that actually
captured the image but this was another
reason we turned it off after 10 years
the number of people around who even
remembered the operating system that we
were running and the and and knew how
the software worked and so on was
getting quite small early you know it
needed to be repaired a few times and so
on we used to joke in the early days
that things happen so fast on the web
that it was sort of like dog years you
know one year on the web was seven years
in real life and it was kind of fun that
this went from being a novelty to being
a where did this whole webcam thing
start to being a historic artifact to
being something that people pined for
when it was being switched off because
of their you know nostalgic memories all
in a 10-year period you know there's
almost nowhere else in the world in
general where where things can go from
novelty to antique in ten years and so
that was part of the fun of it
so sometimes he fought please wood dies
he often would make backup copies let's
try this one sounds more hopeful and so
there was this game called Lander